[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d' pas
masquer ben oui c'est la situation
sanitaire qui le veut qu'il existe un
peuvent consacrer à la politique de la
ville à l'éducation aux quartiers aux
cité éducative
c'était assez nouveau cette nouvelle
structure qui met en avant justement
l'éducation dans les quartiers pour
reparler je suis avec catherine arenou
bonjour vous êtes de la maire de
chanteloup les vignes
vous êtes aussi la présidente activity
activités on en bout en un mot c'est l'
agence d'insertion des yvelines vous
savez que les départements ont la
compétence insertion la prise en charge
vers l'emploi cae l'insertion des
bénéficiaires du rsa entre autres et
donc cette agence qui a été créée 2015
2016 et qui actuellement amis à l'emploi
un peu plus de trois mille bénéficiaires
du rsa savent aussi avec raphaël se dit
bonjour bonjour monsieur le préfet vous
êtes préfet pour l'égalité des chances
auprès du préfet des yvelines absolument
là aussi je vous vous demandez pas ce
que peut-être que les gens ne savent pas
ce que c'est qu'un préfet à l'égalité
des chances délégué à l'égalité des
chances c'est un préfet c'est un préfet
sedan préféré voir l'or qui est
compétent pour trois grandes thématiques
la politique de la ville d'abord
l'insertion sociale des personnes en
difficulté et la lutte contre les
discriminations somme au dos et les
trois grands domaines d'intervention du
préfet délégué à l'égalité des chances
et il y en a maintenant depuis 2020 dans
tous les départements d'île de france à
l'exclusion de paris qui a une
organisation particulière mais donc dans
les sept départements villes de france
et vous êtes en poste depuis juillet je
suis le premier préfet délégué pour
l'égalité des chances dans les yvelines
depuis juillet 2020
et puis nous sommes en visio avec
séverine ponsin olivier bonjour bonjour
bonjour vous êtes chargé de mission
éducation aux médias et à l'information
les mii vous êtes la coordinatrice
académique du clemi de la cabine de
versailles et au fond vous occupez
justement d'aider de l'éducation à la
formation dans l'est dans les classes
des collèges et des lycées
voilà alors plus précisément de
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information qui incluent toutes sortes
de médias numériques en particulier
voilà on organise toute l'éducation aux
médias pour les établissements des
quatre départements de l'académie de
versailles
et puis dans quelques instants ils
seront rejoints par mustapha larbaoui
qu'est le président des missions locales
pour l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
alors on va évidemment parler beaucoup
d'éducation de la cité éducative de deux
chanteuses divine qui sera la première
peut-être c'était éducatif qui existe
qui sort en tout cas qui verra le jour
ce qu en 2024
mais peut-être avant on va commencer par
un peu d'actualité et la première
actualité évidemment c'est le
confinement
[Musique]
alors posez une question un peu général
commence pas sophos ce confinement quel
retour vous avez l'impression qu'il est
assez différent du duduk au film ou du
mois de mars
oui il est différent très différents
pour deux raisons d'abord parce qu'il
est moins violent vous savez que c'est
toujours moins violent de vivre quelque
chose qu'on connaît plutôt que de partir
dans la certitude donc il est pour la
première semaine un peu comme un violent
puis la vraie différence pour nous c'est
que les enfants
les collégiens les lycéens vont dans
leur lieu de scolarité et que on voit
tout de suite que ça ne désocialise pas
puisque ça avait été une de nos
problématiques extrêmement importante la
désocialisation des enfants donc des
familles et là on voit que la relation
se fait se continue la relation à
l'enseignant se continue la relation
entre parents et enseignants se continue
elle n'est pas virtuelle elle est réelle
et je pense que ça va vraiment changer
ce confinement la zoophilie d'ailleurs
le premier trop finement le risque au
film ans et le creusement des inégalités
sociales or c'est un risque qui existe
évidemment toujours parce que le
confinement ne se vit pas partout de la
même façon mais peut-être qu'on a pris
des leçons du premier
peut-être je l'espère en attendant les
inégalités se sont creusées les gens
sont devenus plus précaires plus pauvres
beaucoup de petits boulots n'ont pas été
reconduits il ya des gens qui ont perdu
leur emploi parce qu'ils étaient en cdd
et puis les enfants ont creusé les
inégalités parce que tous les
territoires pas de la même façon partout
mais dans nos quartiers politique de la
ville oui ils ont été plus éloignés plan
pour plein de raisons 1
quelquefois l'apprentissage de la langue
française quelquefois la halle à
l'électro nice mal la relation difficile
dans ce monde dans un monde virtuel
la non capacité des parents à
accompagner alors c'est pas vrai partout
et moi je pourrais vous dire que c'est
pas vrai chez nous puisque la cité
éducative
l'objectif cité éducative et
l'organisation site éducatif qui existe
chez nous depuis janvier 2019 et qui
s'est concrétisé par un vrai travail là
cette année en 2020 a permis de ne pas
perdre d'enfants ou n'ont pratiquement
pas dans ce temps de confinement
monsieur le préfet justement c'est une
préoccupation évidemment vrai et pour la
préfecture est pour vous ce confinement
et samir qui est absolument c'est une
préoccupation on redoute beaucoup que ce
confinement entraîne une aggravation des
inégalités sociales et c'est vrai que le
maintien de la scolarité des enfants
constitue un phénomène qui rend le
confinement - durée moins radicales pour
les personnes qui y sont confrontés dans
les quartiers en politique de la ville
on est très attentif aussi un risque que
ce confinement prive des personnes de
revenus auxquelles elles ont accès de
buzz d'accès aux besoins essentiels on
met en place
on renforce les distributions
alimentaires en force l'ensemble de
l'accès aux soins de première nécessité
parce que c'est une des problématiques
on avait eu lors du premier confinement
de vue des personnes qui étaient
confrontés à une difficulté d'accéder à
des besoins et à des services essentiels
là aussi si vous ne citez pas encore en
poste
bouvier confinement il ya peut-être eu
des savoir faire quoi qu'on a acquis il
ya eu un apprentissage il y avait un
apprentissage
et puis c'est le côté un peu bizarre de
ce deuxième confinement c'est à la fois
on a appris beaucoup du premier donc on
a corrigé des choses qui étaient
peut-être un peu excessif dans le
premier film on anticipe mieux les
difficultés et en même temps comme c'est
une répétition
on sent qu'il génère et angoisse
supplémentaire quand est ce que tout ça
va se régler et notamment chez les
commerçants chez les entrepreneurs il ya
une vraie crainte de vivre comme ça dans
un univers de stop and go permanent ce
qui génère beaucoup d'incertitudes et
beaucoup de craintes
c'est vrai qu'on a un peu de cette
situation toutes choses étant égales des
d'exigeant qu'ils ont pris nos otages
vous savez par rapport aux gens qui sont
condamnés à une peine style quand on est
condamné une panne on sait quand ça
finit dans des plots notre âge on ne
sait pas et il ya ce côté là sinon je
l'aurais pas encore une fois toutes
choses étant égales en terme de prix
mais c'est vrai que l'incertitude du
temps et j'ai du temps et des facteurs
sans doute de crainte de ce trail sur la
répétition de l'événement du confinement
génère effectivement chez nos
concitoyens une une crainte une question
légitime quand est-ce que cela va
s'arrêter
quand est ce que tout cela sera terminé
qu'on pourra vraiment reprendre notre
vie notre vie d'avant évidemment
personne ne peut donner de réponse
certains avancent la réponse est
compliqué à cette question que je me
risquerais pas des pronostics sur ce
point et qui dépendent beaucoup de
beaucoup de facteurs a les yeux il ya eu
on a beaucoup parlé dans la presse de la
nuit d'halloween notamment à strasbourg
et dans les yvelines ça a été des deux
poings ou somme didier dds que est ce
que ce ne peut exagérer des informations
qui sont parus là-dessus on a parlé
notamment de son tour des vignes
catherine arenou oui pour pour ce
conseil qui s'est passé sur nos
territoires à chanteloup mais dans
toutes les collectivités qui rend des
quartiers politique de la ville autour
ça a été très exagérées mais
je vais me lâcher les médias attendent
avec impatience cette journée
d'halloween pour pouvoir dire que c'est
exagéré donc la leur dans leur coeur de
métier
moi je pense qu'il faut être dans ces
périodes de confinement plus qu'ailleurs
alors que la seule relation entre une
partie de la population et la réalité
c'est les réseaux ou les médias
officiels
les réseaux sont on le sait est
extrêmement compliqué à manoeuvrer
par contre les médias officiels doivent
être très très attentif au fait qu'on ne
peut pas augmenter sans arrêt ou donner
une impression plus grande que la vraie
réalité dans cette période où où les
habitants se côtoient moi ont le moins
le sentiment de la vraie réalité et ne
l'ont qu'à travers une radio ou une
télévision
je pense que pendant le temps du
confinement on a quelques obligations
encore plus importante enfin nous dans
ce que nous disons et vous les médias
dans ce que vous rapportez donc vous
pensez vous pas qu'il doit y avoir une
plus grande responsabilisation des ddd
médias et c'est vrai que vous êtes vrai
papa comme ça y est des passages obligés
dans la presse ce qu'on appelle le blé
autrefois des marronniers et ça revient
chaque année 1 c'est vrai pour être
clair sur le week-end d'halloween dans
les yvelines
quand on redoutait beaucoup bien sûr il
ya eu dix véhicules un son design de
véhicules incendiés et c'est à nous de
fait google alors c'est beaucoup trop il
faudrait que j'en ai aucun c'est en même
temps par un département à feu et à sang
dont il faut il faut trouver l'équilibré
dans la communication
d'autant que les gens se nourrissent
aussi de la communication qu'ils voient
dans la presse pour décrire la situation
s'il ya une sorte de révéler à ses
citoyens d'émulation avec l'application
médiatique donc il faut faire faut
garder la mesure des choses
les choses étaient sous contrôle pendant
le week-end d'halloween dans les
yvelines
séverine conseil olivier justement
catherine arenou parlait justement de
cette différence entre les réseaux
sociaux et la presse s'est alors on
entendra tout à l'heure de cette
éducation aux médias mais c'est un des
points essentiels a justement que vous
enseigner aux enfants enfin aux élèves
oui effectivement dans notre mission il
ya tout
toute cette partie qui va consister à
comprendre comment fonctionnent les
réseaux sociaux comprendre qu'il ya
certes de l'information mais aussi
beaucoup de désinformation ou simplement
du divertissement et notre la mission
des enseignants en tout cas c'est de
leur apprendre à se repérer là dedans à
hiérarchiser et à comprendre d'heureux
parmi toutes les informations qu'ils
reçoivent dans tous ces canaux à savoir
identifier la bonne information
alors pour finir avec le confinement il
ya eu il ya eu 7
ce débat sur les commerces essentiel pas
essentiel des mers ont pris des arrêtés
qui était en contradiction avec ce que
demandait le gouvernement vous en avez
pris vous même
bien sûr que non bien sûr que dans un
bain jusqu'à preuve du contraire le
maire ne peut pas s'opposer à une
décision qui lui est supérieur sur le 6e
tour lui qui est théoriquement les
représentants de la loi sur son
territoire et bien justement nous allons
faire le point là tu le point juridique
la tue avec vincent couronne vincent
couronne est le fondateur d'un mouvement
qui s'appelle était docteur droit
quéveau fondateur de l'humour des
surligneurs qui justement donner des
précisions juridiques sur un certain
nombre de débats et il va nous expliquer
justement ce qui se passe en matière de
commerce d'ouverture de commerce non
essentiels et d'arette de certains
arrêtés deux municipaux
[Musique]
bonjour à tous chers patrice aujourd'hui
je vais vous parler des arrêtés anti
fermeture des commerces non essentiels
vous savez ces arrêtés compris des
maires comme à béziers à brive ou encore
ali mais à côté de mantes la jolie pour
permettre aux commerces fermés par le
confinement de rouvrir
eh bien ces arrêtés sont illégaux
pourquoi parce qu'en france
lorsque le gouvernement décide et bien
les maires ont l'obligation d'exécuter
l'ordre
c'est bien normal c'est ce qu'on appelle
la hiérarchie des normes qui fait que la
france est un état et non pas juste une
agrégation de communes
l'autorité de l'état s'impose donc toute
entière sur l'ensemble du territoire
et si il est a dit que la librairie doit
fermer le maire ne peut pas l'autoriser
à ouvrir
mais la police municipale llc que
l'arrêté est illégal parce que dans une
situation de tels arrêtés ont été pris
eh bien il ya des confusions quel ordre
le commerçant doit il respecter le
décret du gouvernement qui impose le
confinement ou bien l'arrêté du maire
qui l'autorisent à ouvrir et comme la
police municipale c'est que cet arrêté
est illégal est notons qu appliquer le
décret et verbaliser les commerces non
essentiels qui ouvre notre libraire peut
donc plaider l'ignorance
le code pénal prévoit en effet que n'est
pas pénalement responsable la personne
qui justifie avoir cru par une erreur
sur le droit qu'elle n'était pas en
mesure d'éviter pouvoir légitime et
légitimement accomplir l'acte l'amande
pourrait donc être annulé mais toute
cette confusion créée par des mères qui
tantôt ont voulu s'opposer au
gouvernement pour des raisons de
politique politicienne
tantôt ont voulu attirer l'attention sur
une vraie question de survie des petits
commerces face à la grande distribution
toute cette confusion est en train de se
dissiper
car depuis quelques jours tous les
tribunaux administratifs saisie suspende
1 1
les arrêtés municipaux anti fermeture
des commerces
car il s'agit bien de décisions
illégales et ses suspensions ont tous
moins un mérite
rappeler qui est le premier responsable
de la gestion de la crise sanitaire le
gouvernement et non pas les mères au
fond très clair merci beaucoup vincent
couronne une réaction le préfet le point
était très clair a effectivement les
arrêtés qui sont prises sont illégaux
donc ils sont immédiatement déférés par
la préfecture au tribunal administratif
qui immédiatement les suspend donc non
seulement c'est illégal ça envoie un
mauvais signal
on a besoin je crois de de cohésion
autour des règles sanitaires on est face
à une épidémie dont on a dit qu'elle est
angoissante pour nos concitoyens donc il
faut que tout le monde tire dans le même
sens et puis ça ne sert à rien parce que
c'est immédiatement suspendu donc
vraiment ce sont des des arrêtés qui ne
faut pas prendre
madame le maire oui les élus locaux ont
d'autres moyens que de faire de
l'illégalité ils sont les premiers
concernés par la vie économique de leur
territoire et ils ont capacité parce que
parce qu'ils existent parce qu'ils sont
en non parce qu'il ils ont des
associations d'élus de faire remonter un
certain nombre de d'incompréhension ou
de propositions ça c'est le couple est
mono rôle là on est complètement dans le
rôle de vous avez pris une décision sur
le plan national localement voilà les
risques et nous remontons vers le
gouvernement pour essayer de lui faire
comprendre là les problèmes de proximité
et à mon avis c'est beaucoup plus
efficace que d'être dans l'illégalité et
de donner le sentiment aux habitants
tous les habitants commerçants au nom
qu'il suffit comme ça d'un claquement de
doigts pour s'opposer une décision
nationale ce qui de toute façon sur le
plan de l'éducation aussi civique n'est
pas de trading n'est pas très bonne
absolument vous avez raison après ça
n'empêche pas qu'on peut être en
désaccord sur telle ou telle mesure
c'est tout à fait autre chose
il est gagné l'onu entre les maires le
préfet pour discuter lorsqu'une décision
pareille mal adaptés ce qui est pas le
cas en plus ya pas eu beaucoup de cas
dans les yvelines nous semble city il ya
deux cas à mon cas là ma connaissance en
développement des yvelines d'arrêté qui
ont été contestés et des yachts et les
grains canule annulée par le pôle
féminin administratifs à la première
fois d'actualité c'est donc le
confinement il a un autre qui était
important c'était la rentrée scolaire et
puis à prendre
on avancera la cité éducative donc la
confiance qu alors rentrée scolaire où
ça s'est passé par exemple chez vous
c'est vrai qu'il y avait cette tension
après le après l'assassinât de sa mère
pattie à conflans sainte honorine
il ya beaucoup de craintes sur la façon
dont la rentrée pouvait se passer
peut-être de certaines appréhensions des
professeurs comment ça s'est passé chez
vous non plutôt bien mais il faut savoir
que le corps enseignant dans sa totalité
c'est à dire qu'il soit pour le primaire
maternelle ou collèges ou lycées étaient
très inquiets et à juste titre de cette
rentrée qui cumulait deux difficultés
une difficulté sanitaires et une
difficulté d'ambiance terroriste avec
avec un enseignant qui avait été touché
c'était moi je pense que pour le corps
enseignant je pense qu'il ya eu une
succession d'erreurs pour le corps
enseignant il fallait à mon avis les
donner du temps au temps puisque c'était
quand même quelque chose qui avait
besoin d'être d'être réfléchi en groupe
pour pouvoir être transféré sur sur les
verts les enfants inverse une éducation
des enfants
et puis il y avait le deuxième le
deuxième problème qui était cette
nouvelle donne sony sanitaire qui
faisait qu'en plein confinement les
écoles de marche les écoles
fonctionnaient mais qu'à partir de 6 ans
les enfants porter un masque si quand
même pas anodin autant les collégiens
sur six mois le mois de mai autant pour
les tout petits bouts de six ans était
pas obligatoirement faciles c'était il y
avait beaucoup de familles qui n'avaient
pas encore eu le temps de prévoir et
pratiquement il ya beaucoup de
collectivités en tout cas des collectifs
terrain politique de la ville moi j'en
ai vu beaucoup nourri compris qui avons
très vite en 24 heures commandé des
masques pour enfants pour pouvoir les
distribuer largement à toutes les écoles
dès la rentrée du lundi
parce que c'était une inquiétude de plus
un pour les parents mais vous avez
raison il beaucoup d'enseignants qui
sont peu l'un de vos fonds d'être un peu
pris par le temps de pop
on va avoir pu discuter ensemble de la
façon dont il fallait faire ça tu
rentrais reparler de ce qui s'était
passé
donc c'était assez compliqué
c'est vrai une pensée olivier justement
est ce que vous vous avez alors c'est
pas tout à fait votre votre métier mais
est-ce que vous avez des retours
justement des enseignants sur cette
cette rentrée et est-ce qui vous ont
parlé de comment à la fois gérer et
l'émotion et l'éducation
alors oui effectivement enfin on a eu
des retours parce que une rentrée qui a
été très difficile comme il vient d'être
dit pour tous c'est un métier qui a subi
beaucoup de pression depuis quand même
quelques mois qui restent voilà c'est
dévaloriser à qui on accorde assez peu
de reconnaissance en général et là on a
mis beaucoup de poids sur les épaules
des enseignants donc non la rentrée n'a
pas été facile c'est certain et on
espère tous que après après ces semaines
difficiles on va redécouvrir un peu le
rôle de des enseignants leur engagement
en fait dans la transmission de toutes
les valeurs de la république donc comme
d'habitude ils font front quoi qu'il
arrive leur métier leur apprend leur
apprend à faire face à des tas de
situations parce que être enseignant
c'est savoir faire face à tous je pense
que le fait de n'être pas retourner en
classe dès lendemain du drame a permis
vraiment d'apaiser la charge
émotionnelle qui autour de cet événement
et et les enseignants l'ordre a
collectivement mais individuellement ont
déjà pu réfléchir à comment parler aux
élèves de ce qui s'était passé
trouver les mots la façon de partager et
aux élèves afin de partager avec les
élèves un message sur la liberté
d'enseigner et la liberté d'apprendre
mais c'est certain que cette minute de
silence a dû être très très chargé en
émotion pour les enseignants est ce que
le préfet de retour deux minutes de
silence côté plus ou moins bien
respectés tout s'est très bien passé
dans un contexte qui était très
difficile les professeurs étaient saisis
d'effroi part sur la sauvagerie de
l'attentât dont a été victime leur
collègue
le contexte sanitaire nouveau s'imposer
à nous et aux enseignants
la situation sécuritaire dans le pays
nécessitait une prudence particulière
donc trois facteurs qui a même contribué
à faire de cette rentrée un exercice
excessivement difficile duquel les
professeurs se sont très bien tirés et
on a pas eu d'incidents qui me sont
remontés pendant les différentes minute
de silence qui ont été organisées
maintenant je veux dire aussi que la
minute de silence qui a été organisée
qui était un instant de recueillement
dans lequel les autorités de l'état
était présent dès côté des des
professeurs de conflent ce n'est pas la
fin du dialogue et la fin de la
réflexion autour de ce qui s'est passé
c'est un dans le département des
yvelines
plus encore qu'ailleurs c'est un
événement qui nous a tous profondément
marqué et qui continuera je crois de
marquer durablement les enseignants et
les élèves
justement c'est vrai que pour ça vous le
disiez lévis et d'éducation aux médias
et à la formation
évidemment la question des caricatures
du droit d'expression de liberté
d'expression forcément va se poser aux
enseignants qui dirigent ces classes
alors elle se pose déjà depuis longtemps
parce que toute façon enseigner la
liberté d'expression ces programmes de
tous les élèves
que ce soit en éducation morale et
civique en éducation médias
l'information en histoire géo en
français on peut l'aborder dans
différentes disciplines et partager les
valeurs de la république c'est de toute
façon une des premières compétences des
professeurs après chacun a la liberté de
choisir ses supports ses méthodes pour
enseigner c'est ce qu'on appelle la
liberté pédagogique
toutes ces questions peuvent être
abordés le sont déjà le sont moins
régulièrement et sur le choix des
caricatures voilà chacun est libre de
choisir son support mais ce qui est fait
très régulièrement et le plus souvent
c'est qu'on présente pas comme ça une
caricature sans aucun contexte toutes
les questions au cours de la la liberté
de la presse de la liberté d'expression
tout ce qui garantit le
bon fonctionnement de la démocratie
c'est aborder de différentes façons par
des exemples part de la pratique c'est à
dire faire pratiquer aux élèves eux
mêmes la liberté d'expression en faisant
des dessins en publiant des médias tout
en ayant bien conscience des limites de
la loi et du fait d'être capable de
repérer en fait tout ce qui est en outre
pas cette loi qui encadre la liberté
d'expression il ya trois domaines en
fait dix autres qui sont importants
protéger la liberté d'expression c'est
le rôle de l'état du président de la
république l'expliqué ses rangs le rôle
des enseignants
et puis publié c'est le rôle des
journaux et c'est peut-être pas toujours
facile d'expliquer à des élèves
il ya trois niveaux qui ne se confondent
pas ce désir de protéger sans être
forcément d'accord avec ce qui se publie
et et c'est peut-être ce qu'est ce qui
dans certains peut-être dans certaines
dans certaines rues ou dans certains
états et théocratique est moins
compréhensible c'est ça qui est aussi
compliqué va parler c'est le rôle c'est
le rôle des enseignants d'expliquer que
la liberté d'expression n'a pas pour
limite ce avec quoi on n'est pas
d'accord la liberté d'expression c'est
la liberté d'expression sa seule limite
l'ordre public et le blasphème la
liberté de critiquer une religion ne
fait pas partie des éléments qui peuvent
restreindre la liberté d'expression il
faut être très clair là dessus c'est un
message qui est parfaitement compris par
la très très grande majorité des élèves
et des enseignants il n'ya pas dessus
d'eux mais il faut le marteler
alors même si elle explique sa voix une
pensée aux milliers peut-être que il
faut il est peut-être une distinction
entre l'espace scolaire ce que vous
disiez ont choisi en public dont on
montre pas nous forcer monde n'importe
quelle caricature
et puis l'espace public des adultes
c'est pas tout à fait le même
de même domaine alors c'est à dire que
je suis pas sûr de comprendre la
question je veux dire par là
mais autant on peut dans le domaine qui
est celui des adultes
charlie hebdo publié des caricatures
qu'il a envie de publier et c'est normal
peut-être que quand on enseigne qu
est-ce que c'est une caricature on
choisit c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
tout à fait dans le même domaine n'est
pas obligé de montrer ce que vous disiez
d'ailleurs toutes les caricatures qui
sont pu dire oui alors la caricature ne
se réduit pas à charrier dans moins de
la loge vip et justement l'éducation
nationale ou le clemi mais disposition
des enseignants tout d'état de
ressources pour contextualiser parce que
en une éducation médias l'information
l'éducation morale et civique en lance
pas comme ça un concept sans aucun
contexte c'est à dire que le canton dit
que les enseignants doivent partager les
valeurs de la république c'est pas
simplement les expliquer cd faire vivre
quand on veut on n'explique pas
l'égalité vous fait vivre l'égalité on
n'explique pas la liberté d'expression
on la fait vivre donc la faire vivre eh
ben c'est s'est expliqué qu' on peut
débattre on peut en quoi le débat va
permettre d'arriver à penser plus loin à
se construire sa propre représentation
du monde et sa propre représentation des
idées et sur les supports ont fait
totalement confiance aux enseignants
pour qu'ils soient en mesure de choisir
des supports qui sont adaptés et à l'âge
de leurs élèves et à leur progression
d'enseignement voilà ça c'est quelque
chose qui est incontestable sur leur
leur légitimité à choisir ces supports
est justement en tant que l'été défense
on sait bien que tout les tous les lieux
d'apprentissage toutes les écoles on
peut pas oublier la même chose forcément
même si même si
la laïcité oblige à ce qu'on enseigne le
même enseignement partout je veux dire
il ya des procédures qui sont
différentes selon les quartiers non
selon les écoles je suis pas compétent
en matière de renseignement inlassable
et sentir les quartiers c'est pour que
ses abonnés bien les quartiers
je peux comme inscrire dans ce qui a été
dit il faut faire confiance aux
enseignants qui sont en première ligne
au contact avec leurs élèves qui ont la
formation les outils pédagogiques et la
capacité à permettre le discernement il
faut leur faire confiance
et puis il faut les soutenir derrière
c'est à dire quand
quand les choses deviennent difficiles
il faut qu'ils aient vraiment il ya tout
un travail qui a été entrepris par
l'éducation nationale notamment sur ces
dernières années pour renforcer le
soutien des enseignants
dansez dansez affaire difficile mais
précisément quand c'est difficile
précisément dans les quartiers sensibles
il faut pas éluder ces questions parce
que ce serait trop compliqué à aborder
donc il faut il faut aborder ces
questions
évidemment adaptées à l'âge des élèves
adapté à ce qu'ils sont en mesure de
comprendre il s'agit pas non plus de
délivrer un discours qui serait
inapproprié et puis il faut soutenir les
enseignants dans la délivrance de ce
message mais on a vraiment besoin d'eux
ils sont et c'est pour ça que cet
attentat nous assis a tous marqués ils
sont des gardiens des vigies importante
des valeurs républicaines et nous avons
besoin d'eux particulièrement dans les
territoires en politique de la ville à
evry un réseau alors les villes sont
compétentes en matière d'école de
primaire vous avez surtout d'enseignant
après après les après la précieuse
d'horribles crimes ou oui j'étais en
contact avec beaucoup d'enseignants de
deux directeurs ou directrices d'école
de les principales des collèges où
c'était plus que nécessaire d'abord
parce qu'on avait une rentrée à préparer
même si les insignes acteurs vacances
mais parce que je savais que ça allait
être lourd lourd à porter pour pour tous
moi j'ai une confiance absolue dans les
enseignants on n'enseigne pas pareil
partout mais on a le même objectif
faisait devancer ce que je voulais comme
quoi même quand on est parent fait de
l'éducation différentes selon ses
enfants parce que chacun selon son âge
sa perception sa personnalité voilà les
moyens utilisés pour obtenir les
objectifs sont différents mais les
enseignants s'adapte c'est aussi leur
grande leur grand savoir faire c'est de
s'adapter selon leur public pour arriver
aux mêmes objectifs c'est à dire
partager faire partager ces notions
républicaine c'est vrai une pensée
olivier justement le clemi je crois
qu'il ya une classe à chanteloup me
semble-t-il est ce que avec les
enseignants qui s'occupe de ces de ces
classes vous avez des discussions pour
savoir selon les lieux comment on
enseigne même si comme le dit madame le
maire il faut il faut que l'objectif sur
le même partout alors nous oui quand on
forme les enseignants évidemment ils
vont nous poser la question oui mais moi
avec mes élèves je peux pas faire si je
peux pas faire ça donc évidemment on
leur donne des pistes pour aborder
différemment selon l'âge des élèves
selon le contexte socio culturels
économiques éducatifs dans lequel ils y
sont on sait ce qu'on appelle de la
différenciation pédagogique tout
simplement donc les et les enseignants
sont ceux qui connaissent le mieux leurs
élèves sont ceux qui voient là qu'ils
connaissent le mieux leur classe et
comment fonctionne leur classe donc à
partir de quelque chose à transmettre
ils savent généralement quoi utiliser et
comment l'utiliser pour parvenir
comme disait madame arino à leurs
objectifs c'est le cas de leur métier
absolument il le faut il le faut avec
beaucoup de passion et d'abnégation
souvent eh bien on va passer maintenant
elle justement on va continuer dans
l'éducation avec parce qu'il va naître
sont tous des vignes qui sera peut-être
la première en france
ce sont le site et éducative alors
pendant de cette cité éducative de son
coude et vince était simone veil d'un
oui c'est un projet extrêmement
ambitieux parce que il lie à la fois le
projet éducatif est un projet urbain je
pense que c'est d'ailleurs sa
particularité
parce que la cité éducative de
chanteloup dedans avec ce label l'année
n'est pas la première n'est pas la
dernière non plus
le grand projet cité éducative on
l'avait travaillé réfléchi relativement
longtemps sur le plan global puisque
c'était un projet qu'on avait déposé la
ville avait déposé en 2016 à l'urgence
de rénovation urbaine mais le la
labellisation site éducatif sous cette
forme là c'est à dire le savoir faire
ensemble c'est rappelez-vous issus du
plan borloo qui avait été un pays où la
commission voulons absolument qui avait
été travaillé entre autres avec la ville
de grigny qui était porteuse après la
ligne actifs expérience a sélectionné
absolument est alors à
chanteloup-les-vignes oui c'est c'est
deux choses dans le projet éducatif est
au service du projet urbain ce qui est
assez rare généralement vous avez quand
on travaille un projet de renouvellement
urbain et qu'on fabrique à nouveau lieu
de d'école de ce que la rue il y est
donc primaire maternelle même collège
on fabrique le lieu même en travaillant
dans le cahier des charges avec beaucoup
d'enseignants mais on fabrique le lieu
et après on y intègre le projet là on a
voulu faire alors faire dans l'autre
sens elles n'ont pas l'envers d'ailleurs
à l'endroit mais dans l'autre sens ce
qui est à la fois plus compliqué mais
dont on est sûr que ça garantit la
réussite pour plus longtemps donc l'idée
s'est accompagnée d'une une équipe qui
s'appelle indivisible qui a un vrai
savoir faire pour faire partager une
ambition un projet depuis janvier 2019
les enseignants les parents les membres
des associations le personnel municipal
péri éducatives et les enfants et les
jeunes travaillent sur un projet qui et
comment mutualiser comment on fait une
éducation ensemble en prenant le
principe que l'enfant de 3 ans à 16 ans
puisque c'est la fin d'un collège chez
nous selon lisa de la maternelle de la
maternelle au collège en y incluant tout
le temps c'est à dire du matin au soir
que ce soit les jours scolaires ou les
journaux scolaires
comment l'enfant peu comment on peut
porter nous les adultes autour de lui un
projet global et unique jusqu'à la fin
de sa sortie à 16 ans et comme on peut
le faire ensemble avec chacun ses
compétences et ses particularités et de
ce projet là qui a été travaillé donc
pendant plus deux
plus de huit mois a été écrit ça donnez
lui un cahier des charges qui s'est
imposée pour un concours d'architecte et
les architectes ont fait un concours en
fonction ce qui avait été proposé par
parler l'ensemble des adultes du du
territoire et maintenant ce projet c'est
un projet d'architecte qui associe
particulier c'est qu'il n'est pas figé
qu'on pourra eu lieu l'architecte est
retenu et l'architecte qu'on va
continuer pendant les trois ans à venir
as continué à travailler à élaborer ce
projet pour être au plus près de de la
demande et de la mutualisation et du
projet d'aider les enseignants des
parents et des et du père éducatif oui
c'est un projet ambitieux j'ai je crois
que le long tous à peu près 15 millions
d'euros qui va aller danser cité
éducative salle il ya des coucous et non
halal voilà d'où on vient pour qu'on l'a
fait peut être parce qu'on s'est aperçu
que la formule qu'on avait proposé
depuis des années des années des années
de lutter contre l'échec scolaire était
exactement ce qu'il fallait abandonner
et il fallait prendre les enfants tels
qu'ils étaient en analyse en essayant de
découvrir leurs compétences et en
essayant de faire travailler en les
faisant travailler pour leur réussite
c'est que alors que jusqu'à présent ce
que vous condamniez c'était quoi le les
pandas n'est pas parce que je n'ai pas
peur de dire non mais la police exclut
tout la même ça n'est pas du tout la
même
la même façon de faire la lutte contre
l'échec scolaire c'est prendre
l'enseignement qui est fait pour tous et
de dire comment nous on peut compléter
avec des dispositifs particuliers des
moyens particuliers pour refaire rentrée
l'enfant dans cet enseignement prévu
pour tous là le travail pour la réussite
individuelle et collective c'est comment
on développe et on re on arrive à
trouver la compétence de chaque enfant
pour faire travailler un projet commun
donc voilà donc qui a été définie à sa
zone de compétence qui nous paraissent
un peu évidente mais après la compétence
de chaque enfant sera regardé sans doute
avec beaucoup plus d'attention mais il
ya une vraie volonté en plus de toutes
ces tous ces acteurs de travailler
ensemble chacun danse en chacun dansant
dans son savoir faire mais en en prenant
toujours appuyé sur le savoir-faire de
l'autre je vous dis on a eu la première
exemple alors elle
khadim on me dit qu est ce que vous êtes
sûr que ça va marcher on n'est jamais
sûr de rien mais mais on sait que le
projet prévoit de geler tous les projets
précédents n'avaient pas été des garants
du succès là on a vu une première un
premier sphère réelle c'est qu'on a eu
un confinement
on a eu un confinement donc nos enfants
étaient exclues comme tous du milieu de
scolarisation et les enseignants
n'avaient pas beaucoup plus un peu plus
mais pas beaucoup plus de moyens pour
faire de la de l'éducation virtuel sauf
qu'il y avait dans notre territoire il y
avait eu plus d'un an de travail en
commun plus d'un an de connaissances des
uns et des autres plus d'un an de
confiance parce que le mot confiance
n'est pas rien le confiance des uns et
donc les enseignants les directeurs les
principaux se sont appuyés sur tous les
acteurs du territoire pour aller
rechercher telle famille pour aller voir
tel enfant pour aller essayer de
d'accompagner les difficultés et du coup
de continuer à porter un projet ensemble
alors que tout semblait arrêter et les
enseignants les principes qu'on nous le
dise les directeurs d'école nous le
disent il ya un certain d'enfants qui
ont été en fait continue à être
enseignée grâce à cette espèce
d'entourage
global et local d'ailleurs le projet si
j'ai bien compris associe aussi des
familles hamas est obligatoire le
trépied là comme oudi a pas deux il n'ya
pas donc voilà il n'y a pas de lady cat
les premières éducateur ça reste le
parent cheval ça n'est pas lui qui fait
l'enseignement c'est lui qui fait une
grande partie de l'éducation donc le
parent il doit être confortée dans son
rôle d'éducateur
il doit être aussi en capacité de dire
d'accompagner son enfant donc il faut
que la solidarité de tous les adultes
autour de son enfant de la volonté la
solidarité le parent c'est un des
trépieds obligatoires s'est levé
quelques mots rapidement complément ce
que vient de dire madame le maire sur
les cités et créatives les sites et
éducative c'est un programme de l'état
qui consiste à aider les écoles dans les
quartiers les plus en difficulté en
créant autour de ces écoles tout un
écosystème d'associations qui va venir
d'associations et d'acteurs qui vont
venir au soutien des parents des élèves
et des enseignants pour la réussite des
enfants il ya 80 sites éducatifs qui ont
été labellisés plan national quatre sur
le territoire des yvelines et il y en
aura quatre ans les trois autres les
trois autres ces trappes mantes-la-jolie
et les mureaux et puis on aura 40 autres
qui vont être labellisées au 1er janvier
donc on travaille à une extension au
projet et c'est la première fois depuis
longtemps je crois que les tarés investi
autant d'argent dans le fonctionnement
des associations dans les quartiers elle
le fait et il le fait autour de l'école
parce qu'on sent bien que l'école c'est
le centre de là où la réussite dans les
quartiers peut naître à chanteloup c'est
un programme qui est encore plus
particulier si j'ose dire qui est unique
pour le pour le coup enfin ma
connaissance c'est que la cité éducative
comme l'a très bien dit madame le maire
s'inscrit dans un compte dans un projet
architectural
c'est à dire que non seulement va y
avoir ces groupes d'associations qui
existe qui intervient auprès de l'école
mais ce sera dans un lieu unique un lieu
adapté à ce mode de fonctionnement donc
c'est vraiment un projet pilote un
projet unique au plan national qu on
regarde avec beaucoup d'intérêt et qui
s'accompagne donc d'une toute une
dynamique de rénovation urbaine qui
subventionné également par l'état
accompagné par l'état pour faire en
sorte que cette cité éducative h en tout
soit une école expérimentale qui offre
le meilleur service aux enfants
politique de la ville souvent les
enfants politique de la ville on a
l'impression qu'ils ont eu un peu une
école au rabais
là ce sera l'un vers 6h une école de
l'excellence une école du meilleur
service mais adaptée à leurs besoins
adapter leurs spécificités
en tout cas c'est un pari formidable et
on est vraiment ravis d'être partenaire
de la delà de l'amérique change tout
pour le pour le monter c'est un projet
optimiste parce que vous foncez l'idée
de dire il ya de l'excellence c'est
chacun ou s'il a versé excellence à
chalais c'est une réelle avancée un
constat oui mais non mais quand vous
disiez parfois l'échec scolaire c'est
vrai qu'on l'a traité peut-être
différemment et que certains élèves sont
retrouvés exclus du système scolaire
donc il faut procéder autrement c'est ça
c'est que au fond il ya un espoir c'est
chacun des élèves c'est formidable c'est
un regard c'est un certain regard
différent mais moi je suis absolument
persuadé que c'est pas parce que nos
enfants naissent dans un dans une
ambiance extrêmement contrainte
extrêmement difficile que naturellement
ils n'ont pas les mêmes compétences à la
naissance cas hier donc ne le rôle de la
société de la micro société qu'est la
ville c'est d'arriver à
à travailler sur les compétences des
enfants parce que elles existent on est
sûr qu'elle existe simplement elles ne
peuvent pas être mises en valeur dans un
contexte normal tels qu'ils étaient
telles qu'il était jusqu'à présent
donc c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
à la fois réaliste et optimiste est
optimiste parce que il faut être
convaincu que tout le monde sera dans
cette logique là et l'ensemble des
partenaires travailleront et sert ont
décidé d'attendre d'en sortir le
meilleur mais en fait c'est ce qui se
passe à paris à partir du moment la
confiance et c'est d'exercer s'est
développée entre les différents acteurs
en fait chacun faisant confiance à
l'autre ça arrive à savoir ce que
l'autre peut lui proposer pour améliorer
son sens à la fois son savoir faire et
son etc etc en action et c'est assez moi
je trouve que c'est assez enthousiasmant
la vue c'est ce que dans les dernier
comité de pilotage on l'a vu parce que
les principautés principal de collège
les enseignants sont assez en tous
genres je vous donner un exemple ce
qu'on se con
on re comme grande difficulté de dans
nos quartiers c'est l'extrême turn over
des enseignants et c'est le feq surtout
dans la région il dans l'île de france
les enseignants qui viennent dans les
quartiers en politique de la ville sont
les plus jeunes et les moins préparés
les moins préparés ils sont sans doute
très volontaires mais des mois après
avoir avoir des conditions d'exercice
peut être un peu compliqué je faisais le
conseil de classe de la fin de l'année
donc en juin et les enseignants m'ont
dit dans l'école qui va être concerné
donc il va être démoli et reconstruit
les enseignants m'ont dit vous avez vu
madame la maire aucun n'a demandé sa
mutation
cette année parce que nous voulons
continuer à porter le projet éducatif
c'est à dire qu'en fait les enseignants
s'en sont aussi contents d'être les
acteurs de leur propre avenir de
l'avenir des enfants quand vous disiez
alors il ya un coût évidemment il ya des
enseignants des anciens de l'éducation
nationale la kippa kitsap ainsi c'est
plus ce projet mais il ya d'autres
associations d'autres d'autres
intervenants qui sont ils en auront
alors en plus des parents bien
évidemment parce que je veux vraiment
les parents les amis toutes les
associations qui travaillent dans la lch
en périscolaire aide aux devoirs
réussite éducative
et puis il ya tout ce qu'on appelle le
périscolaire le périscolaire c'est la
prise en charge des enfants hors temps
scolaire pour généralement une
socialisation mais aussi parce que les
parents travaillent et que les enfants
ont besoin d pris en charge or ce temps
là ça n'est pas un temps de garde en
tout cas chez nous ça doit pas être un
million de gars ça devait entendre
qu'ils agissent partager un temps sur
lequel il se passe des choses pour
continuer l'éducation de l'enfant c'est
vrai une pensée olivier en tant que cio
puis ex enseignante ils vous dire vous
êtes aujourd'hui responsable des prix
mais c'est évidemment des projets qui
intéressent et qui doivent passionné les
enseignants ces nécessités éducative
déjà à titre personnel sous sa très
enthousiasmant parce que effectivement
c'est un moyen de retisser des liens de
confiance de faire tomber des murs qui
ont pu s'ériger entre l'école et les
familles parce que voilà en chacun est
éteint dans son propre milieu est
justement avant de répondre à votre
question le le lien école famille je
pense qu'il est indispensable de le
le redis c'est vraiment de façon très
très serré si je peux dire pour pouvoir
expliquer aux familles ce qu'on fait à
l'école que l'école c'est le lieu de la
connaissance du savoir et que les
familles le comprennent et que ça on
n'en viennent pas à heurter en fait des
convictions qui sont las du domaine de
la famille le croire les les convictions
religieuses les convictions sociétale
ça ne doit pas se heurter en fait ça
doit ça doit se mêler et se débattre et
se comprendre et c'est donc le fait de
ne pas pouvoir communiquer en fait entre
école et famille c'est ce qui crée comme
ça des descentes de radicalisation
pensées des uns des autres
donc je évidemment ce projet des sites
éducatifs pour nous il est très
enthousiasmant parce qu'il est porté par
beaucoup d'acteurs différents qui ne
sont pas que l'école qui ne sont pas que
la vie qui ne sont pas que les
associations il ya un vrai dialogue
il est multi thématiques se dire qu'ils
portent sur la citoyenneté la santé
enfin des tas d'autres axes et il ya
vraiment voilà une envie de tout le
monde de travailler ensemble dans des
territoires qui en ont vraiment besoin
monsieur se dit aujourd'hui à cette
vieille formule de victor hugo mais elle
est toujours d'actualité
ouvrez une école vous formerez une
prison et oui enfin c'était ccc un peu
résumé mais au fond de la porte de
l'ambassade us avoir de l'importance de
l'éducation dans les quartiers de l'est
dit elle est première
la grande force de la cité négative et
c'est est soulignée par tout le monde
sait que dans on le sait dans les
quartiers l'une des difficultés qu'on
peut avoir c'est que les enseignants se
confronter à un tel d'hôtel difficultés
qui peuvent avoir le premier réflexe de
se replier sur eux-mêmes de replier
l'école sur elle même et là évidemment
ça devient dangereux parce que l'école
peut pas résoudre des difficultés qui la
dépasse l'école son rôle c'est de
transmettre un savoir c'est pas de
résoudre des difficultés sociales il
faut pas lui demander des choses qu'on
lui demandait
et last éducatif c'est justement essayer
de lutter contre ça c'est le d'ouvrir
l'école aux parents aux
aux problématiques de santé aux
problématiques de d'accompagnement à la
parentalité aux problématiques
évidemment de tout le périscolaire et
c'est en faisant cela que l'on peut je
pense abordé la situation de l'éducation
des quartiers dans de meilleures
conditions en tout cas les premiers
résultats que l'on a est également en
termes de dynamique créée entre les
acteurs parce que ça je crois que c'est
vraiment très important et que madame la
maire l'a souligné en termes
d'appropriation par les enseignants de
ce projet un montre qu'on est dans la
bonne direction
c'est un apprentissage aussi la
citoyenneté de l'éducation absolument
tout petit de tous c'est dire que pour
les enfants certes mais aussi pour les
parents facettes c'est la citoyenneté
c'est aussi faire partie faire partie
d'un endroit donc entre autres une ville
où on est tous acteurs de son avenir et
et dont on comprend mieux comme ça les
les
les grandes définition de la république
d'autant plus facilement qu'on est
acteur de son année et qu'on n'est pas
et qu'on n'est pas contre a simplement
de faire ou de ne pas faire ce qu est ce
qui est très intéressant dans notre
projet mais mais c'est penser comme ça
notamment qui est intéressant aussi
c'est qu'en fait on ouvre l'école alors
ça fait très longtemps qu'on parle
d'école ouverte et tout ça mais là on
ouvre physiquement tiers même dans le
projet urbain c'est un le lieu scolaire
sera un lieu ouvert pour l'école pendant
le temps des col ouvert pour autre chose
pendant le temps hors scolaires et lille
sera inclus maison des parents parce que
les parents font complètement partie de
ce dispositif mais ils ont besoin d'être
accompagnés de faire des tonnes un
serveur de choses ensemble dans une
maison des parents un lieu médiathèque
bibliothèque est aussi un lieu de lieux
de restauration pour enfermer pour
enseignants parce que c'est aussi c'est
aussi le temps du partage en stage 2 et
donc l'idée que ça sera ouvert pendant
après avant c'est à dire que ça fait
partie de la ville je pense que ça aussi
ça peut ça peut décloisonner les esprits
assez facilement c'est vrai qu'on croit
donner un petit peu et vous souvenez
vous le disiez dans l'éducation c'est
d'affaires des familles et puis le
savoir c'est la fête de l'école en gros
là il s'agit un peu de cause de tout ça
et quand je parle une citoyenneté ya des
enfants mais j'ai l'impression que si
les parents c'est important aussi il
doit prendre aussi la citoyenneté avec
ses avec ont participé à cet effort
éducatif
c'est à dire qu'ils vont avoir
l'occasion d'être citoyen non pas
seulement à prendre elle est donné
l'occasion de l'aide c'est à dire de
faire de faire partie d'un projet de
ville et d'un projet de vie alors on
fait un petit peu de l'égalité des
sources ont dit souvent dans l'ascenseur
social l'ascenseur social est en panne
est ce que est ce qu'il est vraiment la
france est une caractéristique qui qui
moi me préoccupe c'est qu'effectivement
beaucoup d'argent est investi pour
l'égalité l'égalité fait partie de notre
devise républicaine et en même temps
vous ayez beaucoup d'argent à kéké sur
de la ville on peut pas dire que alors
sapotille la vie de mon jeu
là je serai moins affirmatif et bakar
argent est donné pour redistribuer les
revenus en france est une
caractéristique de notre modèle social
et dans tout le monde qui fait
relativement consensus dans notre pays
toutefois quand on regarde les
trajectoires
c'est à dire quand vous êtes né dans une
famille pauvre est ce que vous accédez
rapidement aux classes moyennes et aux
classes supérieures on se rend compte
qu'en france on est plutôt un peu plus
mauvais que les autres pays de l' ocde
et même ça s'est un peu dégradée alors
oui alors entre la presse et ces pannes
sur d'iraty repas les a laissés aux
grandes écoles les emplois existants on
ad on a des difficultés une forme de
stratification de la société elle y est
plus forte chez nous qu'ailleurs
lorqu'il forte aussi dans d'autres pays
de l' ocde il faut pas être exagérément
négatif mais le la grande enquête en la
matière qui fait référence dit ça il
faut cinq générations pour un enfant
pauvre atteint des classes moyennes en
moyenne dans l' ocde il en faut six en
france donc on serait un peu plus
mauvais que la moyenne
ça pour nous c'est une grande
préoccupation parce que c'est une chose
de savoir que vous avez pas énormément
de revenus mais de savoir que vos
enfants vont être finalement dans la
même situation que vous sans
perspectives d'évolution c'est ça qui
crée du désespoir social donc lutter
pour l'égalité des chances est très
important et ça repose sur à mon sens un
triptyque sur lequel il faut qu'on soit
performant c'est l'éducation on l'a
mentionné c'est l'emploi des jeunes
parce qu'en france on aime
caractéristiques qui explique beaucoup
cette situation qui est que léon un
chômage des jeunes qui est trop fort et
puis c'est la lutte contre les
discriminations on a quand même des
jeunes qui en fonction de leur couleur
de peau de leur quartier d'origine de la
consonance de leur nom vont pouvoir
faire l'objet de discrimination donc ça
c'est important également de lutter
contre ces trois aspects et si on y
arrive ça prendra du temps de produits
temps évidemment là du temps mais en
tout cas si on associations se fixe
aucun objectif et les cités du bâtiment
font pleinement partie on peut réussir à
réduire ce temps nécessaire pour
grand gravir l'escalier ou monter dans
l'ascenseur social
oui vous vous donnez des délais enfin
pour essayer d'améliorer ou c'est
compliqué de lampes par peut pas se
donner des délais sur des choses aussi
plex aussi complexe jeu on peut se
donner des objectifs je pense que voilà
il se faisait des objectifs d'avoir des
sites éducatifs dans un très grand
nombre de territoires on peut donner des
objectifs de réduire le chômage des
jeunes voilà c'est un des objectifs
intermédiaires après l'ascenseur social
il repose aussi sur une dynamique
économique sur la situation globale d'un
pays c'est plus c'est plus difficile de
s'y engager en tout cas à mon modeste
niveau
alors il ya un autre peut-être facteurs
et puis on va conclure l'émission en
parlant de ça c'est vous avez fait
beaucoup à son tous et la rénovation
urbaine
[Musique]
alors vous avez mené une grande
politique de rénovation urbaine chic ou
un premier programme fini dans sa
totalité et même un peu plus je crois
qui a consisté à à démolir pour refaire
une vraie ville c'est dire une vie dans
lesquels on passe dans laquelle on se
sent en ce sens lee protéger mais
surtout une pratiquement 100% de
réhabilitation du logement social
et ça ça me paraissait mais ça nous
paraissait absolument indispensable on
ne pouvait pas continuer à laisser vivre
les gens dans des conditions qui
n'étaient absolument pas respectueuse de
du chèque ils payent un loyer que c'est
du logement social certes mais qui paye
un loyer qu'ils ont et qu'ils le doivent
avoir à la fois le respect de l'endroit
où ils habitent et leur élan vide envie
d'y rester houle envie de bouger mais
simplement avec sa propre liberté sans
la contrainte donc il ya eu une énorme
rénovation urbaine ya eu aussi des
équipements publics qui ont été qui ont
été créés dans le cadre de cette
rénovation urbaine c'est très important
aussi parce que
ça s'est dit un peu partout mais dans la
rénovation urbaine on imagine aussi que
le bo doit se doit pouvoir se construire
ici comme ailleurs la notion du bouquet
d'une nation très relative en est
d'accord mais qui est quand même qui est
quand même très intéressant à partager
donc on a eu des équipements publics à
la hauteur des besoins et des envies
qu'on avait pour les habitants là on est
dans un deuxième programme de
renouvellement urbain qui est qui est
maintenant validé et signée par tous et
qui est qui est bien évidemment autour
de la de la cité éducative parce que ça
va faire un projet énorme sur l'ensemble
du projet mais pas qu'eux qui va
permettre à la marge aussi de continuer
à amener ce qu'on appelle la mixité
sociale en fait la mixité sociale c'est
quoi c'est quoi c'est que un territoire
ne peut pas être exclusivement porteurs
de logement social ou porter
d'habitation il ya des embrouilles à 70
80 % de logements sociaux et la vie ce
sont les vignes avec 80 de possession
logement social les premiers projets ça
n'est pas possible on ne doit pas être
monolithiques comme ça en fait jamais il
doit y avoir dans une ville toutes les
capacités de se loger de tous les
niveaux et puis surtout les habitants
doivent pouvoir avoir eux mêmes d'autres
possibilités de ce logis style veulent
rester dans la vie c'est pas le parcours
résidentiel
donc l'idée ça a été pas seulement de
démolir ça a été aussi de construire des
logements adaptés pour une population
qui a envie de devenir propriétaire
celle de chez nous j'ai très clairement
à charleville le ciblage s'est-elle ces
jeunes parents qui achetaient pour la
première fois il y avait un ou deux
enfants qui avaient envie de s'implanter
donc il y aura d'autres constructions
qui sont faites dans le comme ça se fait
un peu partout en france maintenant dans
le cadre d'une mutation reconstruction
sert qu'on ne va pas s'étendre
on protège j'allais en protège les
territoires qui sont actuellement non
bâti on va reconstruire sur des endroits
qui sont déjà construits mais mais pas
offrir de bonnes qualités de façon à
refaire la ville sur la vie et surtout
petit à petit à faire ce que bon ce à
quoi je suis très attentive mois dans un
an dans une ville où il y a posément que
du logement social
les gens viennent dans le logement
social pas parce qu'ils ont choisi cette
ville parce qu'on leur a proposées et
que souvent ils n'ont pas eu d'autre
choix et donc je voudrais que à un
moment donné la ville de chanteloup soit
la ville ont choisi
devenir à 100% et non pas on a été
contraint parce que quand on est tous
volontaires d'être de vivre ensemble est
bien de vivre dans le même lieu
ça permet effectivement plus facilement
le vivre ensemble appréciés des quelques
dommages collatéraux si tu peux dire ça
ça a dérangé quand il fait de cette
fondation certains trafics haut et c'est
inquiétant qui n'était pas très content
je cite une phrase valérie pécresse
ça c'est dit nous concentrons trop de
détresse sociale certains quartiers
populaires sont au fil du temps devenu
devrait ghetto vous constatez ça mais on
attend surtout les effets sont dix ans
qui sont faits madame la maire laisse ou
binaire éviter cette situation c'est à
dire depuis la création de l'anru c'a
été une réforme je crois d'une profonde
intelligence et d'un profond adaptation
aux besoins ont démoli des tours on en
rénove d'autres ont créé de la mixité
pour justement éviter cette constitution
de ghettos
alors c'est un travail qu'il faut
continuer qu'il faut poursuivre parce
que le tout n'a pas pu être fait dans la
période précédente et donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils aient un nouveau projet de
rénovation urbaine qui se met en place
qui va donner des résultats à chanteloup
dans les années qui viennent mais notre
travail travail que de l'ensemble des
acteurs publics c'est d'éviter la
constitution de ghettos et là où il
existe de créer les conditions pour
créer de la mixité sociale et donc
déghettoïser en quelque sorte les
quartiers en politique de la ville c'est
très important de le faire parce que et
on fait un lien avec un thème
d'actualité
là où il ya des ghettos c'est souvent là
où se créent les conditions de ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le séparatisme des
smiths the arabic exactement il ya
certains dans les quartiers qu'ils
disent mais aussi prendre trop tard ça
va être la conclusion à quelqu'un qui
vous demandez vous pensez qu'il ya
encore non on peut encore agir il faut
agir il faut agir après on aura toujours
des commentateurs pour dire est-ce que
c'est trop tard est-ce que c'est pas
assez mais il faut agir nos quartiers en
ont besoin et on peut agir pour
améliorer la situation dans les
quartiers pas refaire le passé j'ai pas
essayé de leur faire ce qu'il faut c'est
faire l'avenir et est de toute façon ce
qui
ce qui n'a pas été fait avant
effectivement et c'est dommageable mais
ce qu'on fait maintenant je trouve qu'on
le fait mieux avec plus d'intelligence
plus de plus de respect des populations
et plus de risques a aussi de ce qui est
à l'environnement l'écologie
l'environnement parce qu'il faut aussi
qu'on ne qu'on ne se contente pas de
faire de la démolition reconstruction il
faut aussi qu'on prépare une façon de
vivre ici dans nos quartiers comme
ailleurs il s'était dit quand yvan sont
un des abcès l'eau des moyens merci
infiniment
catherine horellou merci infiniment
raphaël sodini si vous êtes préfet
délégué à l'égalité des chances et bercy
vous couvre c'est vrai une pensée
olivier on aura l'occasion à doha parle
évidemment du travail formidable vous
faites avec le clemi
merci à tous les 3es très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de pfs
[Musique]